[Music]
I think the big question in people's
minds is who can they trust for their
information about mental health right on
the one hand we have Big Pharma and
there been some incredible breakthroughs
I I'm a psychiatrist i prescribed
medications and I find some people
really it saves their lives and you
don't hear that in the media I'm this
week I've heard a number of
antidepressants called a miracle drug a
miracle here and I don't take any money
from Big Pharma I've just used these
medications for over a decade now for
some people their life savers then
there's the supplement industry and the
supplement industry is really largely
unregulated they make a number of claims
that really aren't supported by the
evidence and it gets people into an
ocean this happens a lot where instead
of taking a medicine that's been you
know closely studied and brought to
market and closely monitored they'll be
taking 5 10 15 different supplements
it's hard to know as a physician whether
that safe or not and whether that's
really warranted there's a lot of delay
in terms of people getting appropriate
treatment then of course we have talk
therapies right which tend to take
longer time and cost more money so this
is where I think food comes into the
picture all right one is we all can
agree we trust food right for the most
part if it's a whole food it grows on a
farm I mean their concerns about big
pharma but I've never heard a concern
about little farmers right so that's
where I try to direct people and I also
like it as a psychiatrist that it's one
of my interventions that is absolutely
delicious people like that people can do
for themselves
there's we're in a democratic state ma
that we see still and the embarrassment
that my patients have for a victory over
some of the most debilitating and
disabling illnesses and deadly illnesses
in the world it's um it's concerning as
a doctor I says people sees people just
profoundly ashamed by how they're
feeling and the illness that they have
so I think we have a long way to go I
think we're getting there
I think more and more I've been a
psychiatrist now for gosh what 16 years
there's a change in the conversation
people talk about having bipolar illness
people talk about being treated for
Prussian men talk about being treated
for depression really for the first time
in history in a way that gives me some
hope if we can have a more open
conversation we can make a bigger dent I
mean now that's what more than 40,000
suicides a year in America we have
600,000 veterans with severe traumatic
brain injuries we have a lot of work to
be done and on the frontlines of mental
health I think I just try to remind
myself to sit with my patients to do no
harm and to give them a menu of options
I think that's one of the things that's
gotten missed in this whole discussion
about mental health people talk about
how many people are kind of over
medicated in America and I always like
to point out the 10 percent of Americans
that take antidepressants in the morning
they do that voluntarily because it's
something that's helped them and I think
that when we we talk about an over
medicated society sometimes we miss the
point now I would say that we're a miss
medicated society I've seen a lot of
people in my practice who are just on
the wrong meds for the wrong reasons and
I've met even more people who've never
ever had a trial of even something
natural like st. John's wort that has
incredible evidence that it's a very
very good antidepressant and and I think
that's the part the folks who aren't
getting any help that's the that's the
most concerning part to me because
that's when people end up in real real
trouble
[Music]